you too guys I gotta say the idea of the
two of you in a rom-com together is
absolutely perfect I want to know how it
how it happened Rhys did you just get
out your big book of like handsome
Hollywood guys and go
Ashton Ashton is next he's the one
god well actually kind of I've had to
dust off the bug
um no I bought I was excited to work
with Elaine McKenna and she said to me
why don't we ask Ashton to do this movie
because she was talking to him about it
doing a different movie I was like don't
choose a different movie asked you to do
this movie with us so
um I don't know we've always sort of
been satelliting each other and and it
just felt like the perfect movie for us
too at the ages we're at you know we
weren't ready in the 90s
we were I don't think the world was
ready for this
it was really the the universe wasn't
wasn't prepared for this we were ready
yeah combo I was gonna say
so this movie brings up an age-old
debate and maybe the ultimate question
but I mean New York or la which is the
better City we're deciding now in this
very interview well Ashton always says
LA but I say New York well why are you
gonna pin me off he's totally she
flipped me oh wow this is now it's
aggressive E.T Canada it is aggressive
what's happening here this is an
aggressive approach to interviews Rhys
needs to eat we were supposed to have
lunch she hasn't eaten yet she's getting
a little Punchy reset Los Angeles I said
New York never said that this is
absolutely okay wait a second I said
Miami but nobody asked yeah but Miami's
not on the list because it's not on the
list and nobody wants those kinds of
tickets
it's a hurricane issue I don't care it's
so fun we are you're we're not investing
that reinsurance company you don't want
to get into that listen
okay hold on I'm gonna be absolutely
honest about this if you're between the
ages of 20 and 35 in New York if you're
between the ages of 35 and like 50 and
have young kids Los Angeles once you're
50 go back to New York
a very practical approach and he closed
the book on it too that's it
so awesome uh thank you so much for the
time YouTube thank you thank you have a
great day